foremost skincare speaking of
resolutions is back and giving you the
giving you and your loved ones the gift
of looking younger younger looking skin
for the holidays here's how
oli welcome back so good to be back
rocky
it's been a while because you guys were
sold out which is not a bad problem to
have i feel like vegas bought up
everything we love you guys so much
um so let's talk about obviously it's
the holiday season now and
poor moth skin care makes the perfect
gift
yes i always show my hands first on this
hand i use climate smart skincare
and on the other hand just a regular
moisturizer and rocky look at that
difference
and you know what's different this year
we have to wear masks during the
holidays and you guys have an answer for
that as well
we actually have a special mask called
the smart mask
and we put a mask chain on it so it's
like a
stylish security guard for your mask but
rocky let me tell you about our smart
mask because
everybody is breaking out from bearing a
mask it's called
musk need even people who never had any
kind of breakouts find themselves with
some kind of a rash or
you know a pimple so what we did is we
used a different fabric
these are three layers of an advanced
moisture control fabric why
so that that moisture that you breathe
out doesn't get stuck in your mask
anymore
so no breathing ground for bacteria
problem solved
and it's called the holiday gift of
youth which sounds amazing what do you
get in the gift
well we packed everything in you need
for useful beautiful skin
right now this winter in las vegas
so of course our smart mask with the
beautiful stylish
mess chain is in the gift we have also
our jasmine
flower mask and this is a new mask that
helps you with all this harmful blue
light that is coming out of all the
screens we are so much more in 2020
exposed
that's how we communicate now so this is
your antitote
that it doesn't eat you anymore it's our
iconic
dessert day cream this is the anti-aging
moisturizer
for your zip code this keeps your skin
hydrated and beautiful in the desert
when you get the few moon soon days
where it's going to be a little bit
cooler
a little bit more humidity in the air
you rotate
to the temperate day cream and then
that's the magic
you dress your skin like you dress
yourself the desert day cream or the
temperate day cream
and then at night rocky you use our
uh night cream our luxurious night cream
that
aligns with the repair and renewal
process during the night
and all of it all these five skincare
products
are in this beautiful luxurious kit
it comes also with this vegan leather
bag
it has like a little keychain removable
keychain on it with
snowflakes i put it on my car keys it's
wonderful
all of it made in france all clean
ingredient
and instead of 215 dollars just 99
there you go for more information call
909 243-1459 or just visit
poormawskincare.com las vegas and again
their special holiday offer purchase the
215 dollar gift of youth set
for just 99 dollars